egipto y francia hacen su entrada en la
competencia del festival de cannes
[Música]
el cineasta sueco de origen egipcio
tarek que sale entra en la competencia
del festival de cannes con su última
película boy from heaven una intriga
político religiosa
[Música]
boy from heaven cuenta la historia de
adán el hijo de un modesto pescador que
es recibido en la universidad al azhar
de el cairo un lugar considerado el
centro neurálgico del islam sunita pero
su entrada a la universidad coincide con
la muerte del gran imán se abre entonces
una lucha visceral entre las élites
políticas para nombrar al nuevo líder de
la religión islámica
de siempre
[Música]
por su parte el director francés arno de
play and explora los vínculos tóxicos
entre hermanos y soldados
jeje eso genera el odio absoluto entre
el wish list dos hermanos que viven para
detectarse el uno al otro
[Aplausos]
también la proyección en sesiones
especiales de cannes del último
documental de patricio guzmán mi país
imaginario guzmán esta vez acompaña a la
juventud de su país que en 2019 se alzó
en las calles y obró por la redacción de
una nueva constitución para chile